divide simplify the answer and write as
a mixed number and we have two and
one-fourth divided by one and
three-fourths so the first thing we want
to do since both of these are mixed
numbers is to convert them both into
improper fractions so let's start with
two and one-fourth so we're still going
to have four in the denominator but
instead of two and one-fourth remember
two is the same thing as eight forts so
we have eight forts and then we have
another 1/4 that gives us nine fourths
or another way to come up with this 9
you take 4 you take 4 times 2 which is 8
plus 1 that gives you 9 and then the 1
and 3/4 same process you're going to
have 4 in the denominator and then the
numerator is going to be 4 times 1 which
is 4 plus 3 which is 7 so this is the
exact same problem here 2 and 1/4
divided by 1 and 3/4 is the same thing
as 9 fourths divided by 7/4 and we saw
in several videos already that dividing
by a fraction is the same thing as
multiplying by its reciprocal
so this is equivalent to this is
equivalent to so these are all
equivalent this is equivalent to 9/4 x
times the reciprocal of this we're
taking changing the division operation
to a multiplication and we're taking the
reciprocal of the 7/4 the reciprocal of
7/4 you swap the numerator denominator
or the top number in the bottom number
and you get 4 over 7 now we could just
multiply these we could just say this is
9 times 4 which would be 36 over 4 times
7 which is 28 and then try to put it in
lowest terms or we could do it right now
because it'd be simpler we have a 4 in
the numerator we have a 4 in the
denominator that will eventually be in
the denominator so let's divide our
eventual numerators on our debt ventral
denominators both by 4 so you divide
this 4 by 4 you get 1 this 4 by 4 you
get 1 so now when you multiply it you
get 9 times 1 which is 9 over 1 times 7
which is 7 so we have our answer but
it's writ right now it's an improper
fraction they want us to write it as a
mixed number and to figure out as a
mixed number we can do it in our
now I think we've seen this enough times
we say how many times does 7 how many
times does 7 go into 9 what goes into it
exactly one time but when you take 7
into 9 one time what do you have left
over we're going to have 2 left over
right 7 times 1 is 7 and you're gonna
have 2 left over you need 2 more to get
to 9 so you're going to have 2 left over
so this is one and two sevens and we're
done